Hi there, Steve Kaufmann here.
Today I would like to
talk about the plateau.
Now, the plateau is a concept that
comes up often in language learning.
It's something I think
we're all familiar with.
Uh, you know, we had some initial
success in acquiring new words and
being able to understand some things and
gaining a sense of this new language.
uh, I've often called it
the sort of steep, you know,
blade of the hockey stick.
And then we come to that period where
there's so many sort of low frequency,
uh, words that we need to learn.
We need to learn them because even
though they're low frequency, they come
up quite often and they prevent us from
being able to understand conversations,
movies, books, and so forth.
And it just seems like
this goes on forever.
So we're in the plateau.
How do we deal with the plateau?
Well, it's easy to say,
you know, just keep going.
And I did do a video about Atomic
Habits where I stressed the fact that
rather than worrying too much about,
you know, reaching the final goal,
which might be fluency, uh, you're
better off to develop good habits.
Good habits that you, you know,
regularly, daily, listen, read,
speak, all these things that are
gonna gradually improve your language.
Another habit to try to develop is
that sense that whatever I'm doing,
even if I don't think I'm progressing,
actually it is helping me improve.
The brain is being
exposed to the language.
The brain is becoming familiar
with the language, however
slowly, I am acquiring more words.
So I think the image of the plateau
should be, you know, scrapped.
Because a plateau suggests
that we're not going anywhere.
We're just flat.
Okay.
I like the image of treading water because
treading water means you're standing,
you're sort of in the water, you're moving
your feet, you're moving your hands.
You're basically staying still.
You're not swimming, you're not
progressing, but you're in the water.
And so when we're treading water
in language learning, we are
still immersed in the language.
We are still using our muscles.
We may even be in a lake or in
the ocean, and we can look around
and we can enjoy the scenery.
So, and, and treading water can be,
uh, uh, unless you're, you know, you've
fallen off a boat and you're trying to
survive, but it, it can be, and I've,
in many situations, treaded water and
enjoyed, you know, the, the coastline
on the Mediterranean or the coastline
on this lake or the Pacific outside,
you know, west Vancouver where I live.
And so it can be pleasurable.
And so if we are treading water, we are
exercising our brain, our muscles, our
brain, we are immersed in the language.
And we need to say to ourselves,
this is where I want to be.
So when I'm treading water,
I, I don't say to myself, I'd
rather be doing something else.
How come I'm not moving forward, you
know, I can start to swim, which isn't
necessarily the case with languages.
We can't necessarily speed up our, our
our, uh, you know, learning, uh, process.
But we can enjoy where we are.
We're immersed.
We're immersed in the language.
We are exercising our brain.
Uh, we're enjoying the scenery, we're
enjoying what we're listening to.
And, and remember as again, in
Atomic Habits, you know, we can be
doing a lot of these little things
and incrementally one very small
step at a time, we are improving.
We don't notice it until
suddenly we do notice it.
And one thing that we do notice when we're
treading water is that we're not sinking.
And obviously we wanna be treading water
somewhere where we couldn't be standing.
So it has to be deep.
It has to be deep enough so
we're actually suspended in
the water through our actions.
There's something positive there
that we're doing, and so if we
can take, you know, when we feel
we're not progressing the language,
we are immersed in the language.
We are exercising our brains,
we are acquiring the language.
We can enjoy it.
And so I, I, I think the gist of what
I'm saying here is try to take a more
positive attitude towards that long
period where you are immersed in the
language and you're listening to things,
or you're watching things and you're not
understanding as much as you would like.
And you keep forgetting words and you'd
like to be able to speak better, but
you're still immersed, you're still
in the water, you're in the lake,
you're in the ocean, you are doing it.
And so try to be more positive.
I think a lot of people kind of feel
frustrated at their lack of progress,
so I hope that's, I hope that's helpful.
I mean, obviously you can go and look
up grammar rules when you feel like it.
You can find other things to do and vary
your activities, but accept the fact that
when you are in that period where it seems
you're not progressing, in fact you are.
So enjoy that sensation of treading
water and I'll leave you with a couple
of videos that I've done on this whole
issue of the plateau or that long period
where we think we're not moving forward.
Thank you for listening.
Bye for now.